[Musique]
au cours de la dernière année sur le
radar des décrypteurs le phénomène est
apparu très clairement la croissance
marque et des plateformes numériques
alternatives comme télégramme rambo ou
odyssée des millions de personnes 10 ont
adopté au nom d'une plus grande liberté
d'expression qui ne serait pas présente
sur des plateformes plus conventionnels
comme facebook twitter ou youtube voici
une donnée qui illustre bien ce
phénomène
la plateforme canadienne d'hébergement
vidéo grand bol est passé de 1 million
600 mille visiteurs par mois en juillet
2020 à 31 millions 900 mille visiteurs
par mois au cours du premier trimestre
de 2021 et depuis on peut présumer que
ce chiffre n'a fait qu'augmenter
donc nicolas ses chaînes alternative ces
réseaux sociaux la alternatif ouvre de
nouveaux espaces de liberté mais ça
vient qu'à des informations du contenu
un peu parfois avant de parler de leur
explosion ou de la guerre une popularité
explique once again popularité là qu'on
le doit oui j'ai parlé plusieurs experts
en culture numérique puis un extrémisme
d'ici et d'ailleurs dont québec était
une île et ce qui revient que souvent
ces deux événements d'abord m ledit
plateforme et
10 plates formes en voulant dire y'a pas
d'équivalent français pour ce moulin
mais ça veut dire enlever les
plateformes à quelqu'un dont quand le
prises notre homme s'est fait bannir de
twitter facebook
l'an dernier le 6 janvier après le
fameux ratio du capital ça c'est un
événement qui a mené à une migration
quand même importante doit s'y résoudre
mais aussi en général le fait que les
plateformes moder de plus en plus les
contenus liés à la clé de 19 donc c'est
le cas aussi en 2020 mais en 2021 ça
continue et ça a été même peut-être le
plus intense donc les influenceurs
parfois complotistes extrémistes vont
chercher à l'endroit de rechange où ils
peuvent publier leurs contenus mais
aussi les gens sans plateforme
nécessairement cherchent quelque part où
aller et il se rabattre sur ces
plateformes alternatives le qui
rappelons le existe depuis longtemps
mais qui ont juste vraiment explosé en
popularité dans les dernières années
donc essentiellement le marché pour
cette forme là c'est vraiment élargi en
2021 et c'est parce que les plateformes
principales voulait vraiment assainir le
contenu qui s'y trouvaient bien sûr il
ya encore beaucoup d informations qui se
trouvent sur facebook twitter et les
terrassements et beaucoup de la
désinformation sur facebook ironiquement
provient de ses plateformes alternatives
sont des vases communicants sont les
vases communicants on va voir souvent
des vidéos par exemple de rambo qui
deviennent virale grâce à facebook donc
malgré tout il ya une communication
entre les plates formes là mais bon
cette éco système alternatif le existe
est un élément important aussi c'est que
le thé le tanit est quand même fertile
pour l'exclusion des plateformes parce
que si on parlait des experts il ya
trois quatre cinq ans de plateforme
alternative disait souvent que les
beaucoup d'enjeu de techniques liées à
ces plateformes le parce que bon c'est
pas facile d'utilisation c'était
moyennement fonctionnelle des décès
d'hébergement vidéo ça fonctionnait plus
ou moins bien il y avait beaucoup de
ralentissements alors que maintenant ces
sites se sont améliorées du côté
technique qui fonctionne quand même
assez bien comme solution de rechange ou
plateformes traduire ainsi pas parfait
mais c'est vraiment meilleur que c'était
avant donc clairement ses plateformes
sur un film techniquement parlant ce qui
est à leur avantage très net social sûr
et certain mais est-ce que si tel
avantage d'un influent soeur d'une
figure de proue du conspirationnisme
nécessairement de migrer vers ces
plateformes off d'abandonner les plate
forme plus conventionnelle c'est sûr
qu'avant ce qu'on entendait beaucoup
c'est que ils vont plus avoir accès à un
large public sur les plates formes
traditionnelles donc pour eux ça peut
causer des grandes pertes financières
par exemple plusieurs études qui ont
indiqué que des gens qui perdaient leurs
plateformes comme mes droits yannopoulos
ne font plus l'argent presque une fois
qu'ils sont plus sur des plateformes
traditionnelles qui permettent une
monétisation dont kill you tube par
exemple à chaque ex nombre de vue on
peut collecter quelques dollars mais ça
dépend qui augmente chez les experts
dont il jouit de blackburn de
l'université binghamton à new york lui
il fait beaucoup de recherches sur
l'extrémisme en ligne qui me disait que
c'est plus comme avant pour ces
influenceurs le conspirationniste parce
que ben le noyau dur de la public va les
suivre sur ces plateformes la même si
bon il ya un public général qui sera
plus là mais il ya toutes sortes de
moyens alternatifs de se financer donc
c'est sûr qu'on peut avoir des dons par
péta la terreur on profite des plates
formes et de paypal c'est possible mais
il ya tout l'écosystème de krypton
monnaie qui existent aussi donc des gens
qui gagnent très bien leur vie sur ses
plates formes même sur le public est
plus petit mais bon pas tout le monde
qui s'entend là-dessus à martin geoffroy
le spécialiste en mouvements extrémistes
religieux ou politique qui dit lui que
au contraire c'est vraiment important
pour ces influences world d'avoir une
présence réseau traditionnel parce que
ça leur permet de recruter de nouveaux
adeptes donc c'est un événement de ce
vraiment important au delà des
considérations financières avoir plus
grand public ça te permet d'avoir mais
d'élargir de plus en plus public fait
finalement construite des plates formes
et c'est plus difficile de faire croître
son public c'est plus du chili + nicher
et il donne l'exemple très concrets de
l'excusé trudel on connaît très bien
cette autre figure de proue du mouvement
qui est un homme qui a été bannie des
plates formes fin 20 20 le bain lui
essaie par tous les moyens de revenir
sur des plateformes traditionnelles
comme facebook tout et eu lieu tout
récemment une opération de clonage qui
est mené qui a fait l'objet d'une
couverture dans les médias québécois il
est demandé à tous ses fidèles de ce cri
ou de modifier le nom de leur compte
twitter pour qu'ils se soient alexis que
c'est trudel pour déjouer un peu
hésitant sur le don qui essaient de
faire des coups d'éclat j'essaie d'être
invités à des émissions d'autres
influenceurs conspirationnistes était
encore une plate forme donc dans
certains cas ces titres est souhaitable
pour lui de maintenir une présence sur
la toile ils peuvent pas juste survivre
sur le peuple sur les plateformes
alternatives
mais bon il ya peut-être une différence
régionale la dent aussi on essaie quand
même expert américain qui me disaient
qu'ils peuvent survivre sur ses plates
formes là le plus grand public aux états
unis qu'ici donc peut-être que ça dépend
aussi de wes qui se trouvent dans le
monde et d'ailleurs faut pas oublier que
ce type de connu dans le complot sphère
appelons la comme ce voyage beaucoup
aussi entre le québec et la france les
autres pays de la francophonie c'est
important de noter maintenant nicolas
sion se tourner vers l'avenir qu'est ce
qu'on doit surveiller en ce qui concerne
ces plateformes alternatives y en a eu
dans particulier qui devrait voir le
jour bientôt web et russell ce réseau
semblable à twitter que dans l'autre on
veut partir à la fin février selon les
informations qu'on a sur la plupart du
21 février comme date de lancement les
experts à qui j'ai parlé ont tous dit on
va voir ce qui va arriver avec ça ça se
peut que ça fasse un coup d'éclat ça se
peut que ça change vraiment la donne
dans cet univers de plateformes
alternatives là on va sur ds et aux
distributeurs mais sinon il ya aussi
tout l'aspect de financement des
plateformes qui pourraient venir
changer la donne aussi parce que c'est
plate forme et leur financement est un
peu nébuleux on sait pas exactement
comment qu'elle se finance mais c'est
sûr que si elles veulent faire plus
d'argent l'avenir et continuer à
s'élargir ben ça se peut qu'elle ait
besoin de commanditaires et en général
les commanditaires veulent pas que leurs
marques social du contenu
un nul contre binational quoi que ce
soit globalement de la modération et
financer cette modération possiblement
et si le mode r b ils vont s'éloigner de
leurs objectifs original d'offrir une
plateforme avec une certaine liberté
d'expression parce que c'est ça au coeur
de tout ça c'est la liberté de parole la
liberté de dire ce qu'on veut sans
modération donc est-ce que ils vont
rencontrer les mêmes obstacles et les
plateformes traditionnelles ce sera à
voir